[Music]
welcome to ear biscuits the podcast
where two lifelong friends talk about
life for a long time
i'm link and i'm rhett this week at the
round table of adequate lighting
we're going to be talking about a number
of things including
the witching hour can we also talk about
teleportation
we're going to be talking about
teleportation
okay we're going to be talking about the
difference between being murdered and
assassinated
we got lots of we had lots of good
questions from y'alls why are you using
that voice though that's my new thing
i'm trying it out i've been thinking
about it
i've gotta i gotta i gotta keep
listening yeah
it's easier to do than the monster truck
announcer voice
it's easier to do than this at the dorm
arena
okay it's easier to do than that yeah
you wouldn't think you could get monster
trucks in the dorton arena having played
there which
if you don't know is the
old venue in the middle of the state
fairgrounds in north carolina that we
would always
there would be concerts during the fair
and then we were one of the concerts and
it seems small
um how could you have i've never been to
a monster truck rally
that voice makes me not want to go but
really that makes my voice makes me want
everything else makes me want to go i
think you want to be
in a place that feels too small for
monster trucks if you're gonna go watch
monster trucks
because you want the you want to feel
the impending doom like this
if bigfoot loses control we could all
die
like that's the fun in it dig your own
grave by going
and seeing greg have you watched not in
a long time
okay you have no idea go on youtube
and just type in monster trunk
monster trunk i want to see some big
trunks it's a totally new thing could be
an elephant it could be a chess
caprice classic monster trunk no type in
monster truck highlights what they're
doing in the world of monster trucks
is so much crazier than what they were
doing the last time you checked in
when you checked in last time it was
like bigfoot was like yo i could crush
from cars
now bigfoot and i don't even know if
bigfoot's still around
can like balance on the back wheels
do a full flip what link
they it's basically like watching an
olympic gymnast
it's like simone biles but she's driving
a truck but she's in a truck
she is the truck oh you have no idea
what they're doing in the world of
monster trucks
as soon as crowds happen again i'm going
i just i think
that statement just applies across the
board i want to go
i want to do i want to see you have
monster trucks sound like the most
amazing thing ever because
you you've got quarantine goggles know
this quarantine goggle if you don't know
i do remember
i think jenna went to a
monster truck rally jenna didn't you go
to a monster truck rally
i've been to a couple she's been to a
couple hey and tell him she's on the
video
chat am i not right about what they're
doing she's watching us do this because
i mean what else does she have to do
she's talking
they're amazing right balancing on just
the back wheels
bouncing on the front wheels yeah
balancing on the back wheels just the
front wheels
bunch of trickery have they developed
the technology there was a
parachute there was a type of monster
truck toy
a remote controlled monster truck as a
kid that way you said remote with an l
remote did i remote
well you could at least like i say a lot
of things wrong man i know but i
think you pointed out every single time
i say it i say wolves with an l2 because
it's in there
you don't wolves man have they developed
the toy that i remember as a child that
was a monster truck
that whenever it would it would get
stuck on something
claws would come out like animal claws
would come out of the
wheat of the wheels of the tires and
then it would start
was that climbing over boulders and
stuff what was the name of that thing i
had that
you had it oh yeah i had it in in
california
or something or when i was your friend
when i was a kid i had the monster truck
that had the they were like orange claws
that came out
hands that came out and grip things i
bet it was called the claw
i don't know i'm into it though do they
do that i'm sure they're doing jenna you
seen that
no i haven't seen the claws she hasn't
seen the claws
that's advanced technology well when
that happens i'm definitely going
okay i i think it's like a
fun-loving girl venue i mean jenna's a
fun-loving
girl uh mamrie i know that
mamrie would go mamrie hart would go to
like and then wrestling match and put it
on her and uh
monster truck yeah she's living it up
she's totally living enough i really
wanted to have fun i'd really
i'd really be friends with her like
active friends
like you know we're passive digital
friends like if we see each other
but you know i mean i i guess that's one
of the one of the appeals
she's fun-loving yeah well i don't know
what she's doing lately
that's the thing when you live a life as
exciting
as mamrie then when covet happens
i mean we should check in on her because
there's she's not risk she's not going
to see in wrestling she's not going to
see a monster truck and i'm sure it's
not the same
when you just watch it on television i
mean if you watch wrestling
i watched i watched uh you know what
some of the highlights wrestlemania
and uh there's no crowd of course i mean
sports without crowds already crazy
already sort of weird wrestling without
crowds
i mean yeah it was almost embarrassing
yeah like when
the guy hits the lands on the mat
and you can really hear it like and
nothing else so they're not adding crowd
noise
nba games they have a crowd at digital
crowd they have a digital crowd but they
add crowd noise at certain parts
yeah they do and it's fine the nba games
are
are still fun to watch i don't think
they had crowd noise the whole time
they crowd noise transition at the
beginning yeah like transitional
transitional moments
or whatever but then you get into the
game and it's i don't think there's
crowd noise but you see the people on
the screen are they live
like are they are they video
conferencing in or are they just sending
in footage of themselves as being luke
oh it's live
so they so you can be how do you get to
be one of those i don't know me and like
have had this discussion
i was like look figure out how you
become one of those people who's
watching
and i gave him an assignment uh he
didn't do it but i did find out so
i heard somebody talking on twitter
about um
because i was wondering like you know
people on video chats
their decorum is a lot different than
somebody in the real world right
the chances of you like literally like
whipping it out on a video chat
as a joke are way higher than in real
life
you know what i'm saying oh you're
talking about you're talking about the
twigging berries yeah
and you just know that somebody's like
i'm going to get on there and whip it
out yeah because no what are they going
to do
come to your house and i don't know what
they're going to do but i do know
batter down your door there's two
there's two things that happen the first
thing that happens is
if somebody whips it whips it out or
makes an obscene gesture i think that we
could expand what
is what the difference uh well no you
immediately kick them off the stream and
ban them right
uh but then the second thing is there is
a slight delay
because one of the things you'll notice
if you watch the nba games right now
is there are these very long sometimes
like seven to nine seconds long where
you don't hear anything except the
announcers because they're bleeping out
the profanity of the players
that you typically do not hear because
of the crowd oh
and these dudes are constantly cursing
you know
they're cursing a whole lot less because
they know they're being listened to
but just watch one of the nba games and
they will just oh oh somebody's cursing
somebody's cursing back
it's dropped because all the audio shots
out of the court there's a delay i don't
know what the delay is seven seconds or
whatever just in time for somebody to be
like oh they cursed i'm gonna
so if you show a twig and berries in the
feed they can probably
automatically not show it there's some
technology you know so does that
have you just talked yourself out of
pursuing
being in the virtual assistant the way
that i know that it's live is because
if again i watch a lot of nba and
what's happening now is like when people
like i saw the other day like paul
pierce was watching a celtics game
and he was in the crowd watching a
celtics game
and like they were showing his reactions
to things that were happening he was
like
and they'll show people like somebody
misses a free throw and you'll watch all
the people behind the goal like go
and also when people are shooting free
throws the
they put the opposing team's feed or
maybe it just happened to be that
and everybody's on their screens tried
to get the guy to miss yeah yeah okay
yeah so you're saying they have a
separate feed than like the average
viewer
than the broadcast viewer because theirs
is actually live well but you
oh and then the thing is the seven
seconds seven seconds wouldn't work
right for us well it wouldn't work for
them you would look like everybody was
just very slow in reacting to everything
wow so yeah they probably do have a real
feed
of the game that is no delay for these
special people
and how do you get to be one of those
people i don't know you probably go to
nba.com is it is this turning into an
ad yeah it's probably going to be a.com
ear and it will redirect you to a site
that actually exists
now i was watching a wnba game the other
day
they do not do the crowd they have no
video crowd
and i was like why don't they get a
video you don't get a video crowd what's
up with that
give the women a video crowd it's the
same court right it's not the same court
it's
a court that looks the same the setup is
similar it's a lot of screens
just double the screens what are you
trying to say
that's probably their justification i'm
not saying i agree with well i know that
there's a lot less money in the wnba
than in the nba and maybe they just
don't have money for screens
but it immediately hit me that like
y'all y'all need to do the screens
for the women as well because sure yeah
it's like
it's this really obvious difference yeah
you know i mean how would you
rate yourself i mean we're talking
quarantine quarantined
okay on a scale i want to ten years just
in general you're gonna like your
oh you mean just how i feel right now
yeah i mean let's just have a quick
quarantine update just on a scale of one
to ten uh okay
i had a i had a coming back from
vacation
uh i had a low i had some low points oh
yeah
yeah just i don't know i just you know
something i told you about the
disappointing thing that happened on
vacation would hurt myself or whatever
uh but i actually i had a moment
of uh like a very specific
moment during uh meditation last week
where it was like things sort of shifted
for me oh
ego death it wasn't anything that
that substantial but it was just one of
those things that was like
well no it was just sort of a
realignment of my expectations you know
i
so a lowering of expectations uh well
that would be
that would be a negative way to put it
but i do think that there is a
you know we were talking about this this
morning as a family we were talking
about this
but like i think one of the things that
happens when you are stuck
and you're not able to travel and you're
not able to experience life in the way
that you used to
if you're being a responsible person
that is i mean if
you're not being a responsible person
you're just going on about your business
then
a screw you and b you won't be able to
relate to what i'm about to say
but um if you're being a responsible
citizen in the midst of this pandemic
and so you're limiting yourself from the
things that you would typically
experience
you can and depending on your
personality if you can have a a tendency
to begin to
you know it's just depressing right it's
it's oh yeah it's depressing it's the
same thing over and over again
and i was thinking about traveling and i
was thinking about all the things that i
want to experience and
i was listening to a guided meditation
and uh the woman doing the guided
meditation monster truck guided
meditation there's an
idea write that down
uh but no her voice was very very
peaceful
very peaceful and very soothing um
and she was basically talking about your
inner landscape as opposed
to the world of the the world's
landscape right
and just this realization that sort of
the work that you do on yourself by
being introspective
figuring yourself out and sort of
getting lost in your own inner landscape
and i don't
mean that in like a super self-absorbed
way i mean that and like
becoming who you are becoming the
process of becoming who you're becoming
is something that if you are truly
engaged in it
uh it stands to be substantially more
fulfilling
than the idea of just exploring the
external world right because we we tend
to
we were programmed in a way to think
that the external is where happiness is
it's something outside of you it's a new
house it's a new car it's a new job it's
a new relationship
and everyone falls for this lie right
that
if you get the circumstances the
external circumstances in your life
right you will be happy but every single
person
who has ever gotten the external
circumstances completely right
says this ain't it y'all this ain't it
right perfect example of that
from uh if you're if you relate to our
background
king solomon right yep the whole the
whole
uh ecclesiastic ecclesiastes the whole
book
is about how i had everything any
anything
that i wanted any pleasure that i wanted
and it's all vanity right
it's all there's nothing new under the
sun it's not and so
for me and i have to come to this
multiple times
it's like i was thinking about my
vacation and how i didn't go how i
wanted it to
i another thing again these are super
first world problems
very privileged problems i get back from
a vacation
and my freaking pool area is still not
done right like they still got multiple
things to do
the pool has no water in it etc these
things that
most people don't have period in the
world
or even in the united states and i'm
complaining because mine's not
done yet you know but then i was like
but why am i placing so much
expectation and why am i relating my
happiness to the impending
completion of this project because i
already know what's going to happen
the project's going to get done i'm
going to have a pool and a hot tub
that are exactly the way me and my wife
want i'm going to get in there i'm going
to listen to the music from the speakers
that we've installed
and i'm going to be happy about that for
about
four hours
no we're going to enjoy as a family i'm
not going to i'm going to try not to
take it for granted
but everyone adjusts your barometer
your thermostat changes it adjusts to
whatever you're in and so
there was just this moment where i was
like what about right now what about the
moment right now what about what's
happening
right now find the joy and what's
happening right now find the joy
and figuring out who you are and dealing
with your own [ __ ]
did that happen um yeah it did and i
feel like
i've been able to tap into that for
about a week so i feel good right now
i'm sure it'll wear off and then i have
to go to a monster truck rally i was
just asking for a number
nine wow okay
that's a powerful nine coming from uh
everything you've been thinking about
what about you ah
yeah i think i'm
i mean the vacation was really helpful i
mean if you if you're
you know i don't like giving advice but
i know
everyone can't go on a vacation or you
know but there's
you know just finding something to look
forward to even if it's something small
i got a wreck at the end wow that
it's just make people happy a little i
don't know make some people happy
made my family happy um yeah i think i'm
you know i think i'm at a i'm think i'm
at a good solid eight
right that's a b plus in my book oh yeah
that's i mean because vacation was a
good experience i think i'm still
i'm i'm i'm i was rejuvenated by that
and i'm yeah you know and it's uh i've
given myself a little more
leeway to not not put so much pressure
on myself and try
and beat myself up for what we're not
able to do or
what what i'm not able to accomplish or
whatever
and that but it fluctuates yeah very
drastically
yeah and um you know so it's a couple of
days at a time and then you move to
you know it's like you might move to a
more depressive zone it just it
happens and but there's ebbs and flows
finding something to do to to get out of
it like christie's got
you know not that we need more plants
but like oh you can you always need more
she's like i'm getting more plants i'm
you know i'm getting my hands dirty it's
like these type of things help she's
getting her hands dirty
like she's digging into the dirt yeah
wow like a farmer
she is a farmer she is a farmer she's
planting do you do does she have fruits
um we have lemons that's a fruit
it is a fruit we have pomegranates you
have limes
no we have you should have lots
you should have limes because i was
making guacamole the other night
and uh you have avocados you have
avocado tree i have a grocery store okay
yeah
but what we didn't have and this is
every okay
what is the key ingredient besides
avocados
now i've probably already given it away
onions so i mean a classic
classic guacamole is avocado onions
salt and lime right now you can you can
get a little you can put some peppers in
there if you want
some people put tomatoes i know you
don't like to do that i don't even put
tomatoes in my guacamole because it
makes it look
watery makes it too runny unless it's a
really good tomato
uh but if you use the lime juice that's
in the plastic lime
and that sucker is older than a week or
so
the tang is gone
and we had so many avocados because
jesse does something where there's like
some local farm who brings produce or
whatever you know
and um we had like 12 avocados because
we had a batch that came in and we
didn't touch them
and then we had a new batch come in i
was like baby we gotta have guacamole
and we got a fat of guacamole we gotta
have guacamole
multiple nights in a row and so i was
like i'm going for a
four avocado bowl right now which is a
lot of a lot of guacamole got the chips
to support that
not really man i was really loading up
the chips because i didn't have the
ratio right for that either there's some
toast too
there's some i was also putting it on a
quesadilla
oh that's good i'm using that guy for
area guy fieri
guy fieri is what i say now uh salsa
that we
we had on the show and uh boy that sauce
is good man
you like it yeah sounds pepper smokey
but anyway what are we talking about
they the the line the tang of the
guacamole is the key and i didn't have
the tang and i just felt like a fool
with this really dull lime juice it's
like no matter how much i put in there
from that
dull dead lime juice plastic
green lime thing so in other words you
should have a lime tree i'll come get
some when i'm making guacamole
lando and i are going to remove the
rocks from the rock tumbler
they have reached that's happening
tonight
how many how long has that been going um
since before vacation
constantly moving yeah we went really
overboard on the
on the polished stage there's there's
three different phases you put different
three different grits yeah but like
we did an experiment where we left the
polished stage on there for like a week
longer than we should
but what can we hurt i mean exactly
break the rocks so now we're excited
we're gonna open that thing up tonight
send me some pictures that's what i'm
looking forward to oh i've taken i take
pictures
okay i take progress photos of the
of the rocks after ever before and after
every uh
every stage well you put this on your
instagram this is exciting content
you get a lot of followers doing that
yeah it is i could just it could just be
only a rock tumbler
site all right let's get into some
questions so we're doing good let's ride
that weight yeah
join us you know if you don't if if
you're a four if you're a three if
you're a one right now
it's okay i'll be there next week
again probably you know it's and you
just
you know just make up your mind to
tumble some rocks
figuratively and um
just let let the process work
yes okay we're gonna get into the
questions uh but first we're gonna
remind you that you can go to a little
website that we put together
mythical.com difficult we sell all kinds
of things there and the thing that
we we have brought back multiple times
we brought back this my favorite design
ever related to good mythical morning
and that is the sunrise tea now
we it was a sweatshirt at one point so
it's like it says good mythical morning
and it's got like a sunrise thing
like a sun coming over the horizon this
shirt is black now though and
it's a different yeah we've done it as a
sweatshirt and like teal or whatever
that color was and then a t-shirt and
now we brought it back as a black
t-shirt you're gonna like it oh i love
it i
almost wore it today but i just should
have that i didn't know about the timing
because you know i've had it for a while
i didn't want to i want to spoil
anything too soon
we give the mythical society like a
sneak preview and i didn't want to
i don't want to circumvent that but i
was wrong it's out check it out
mythical.com also subscribe to this
youtube channel that you're watching and
listening to your biscuits on yeah click
that bell
it's so easy just do it right now it
doesn't cost let's go ahead and do it
just a reminder
that we're here for you every week do
you have something unused do you have
something against subscribing
just go ahead and i'm gonna try i'm not
gonna bombard you who knows what we're
gonna say
you'll just know when we're back okay um
tavin maskari asks
at what time of night do you consider to
be the cutoff of
late night and early morning say go
downstairs and your
kid is up at 3am do you say
what are you doing up so late or what
are you doing up so
early ear biscuits
3am and i'm not even going to go into
any sort of
i'm not going to ask myself why i think
this but just 3 a.m
middle of the night late night
that's the middle of the night is not
i mean technically technically midnight
says i mean it's when it it we all know
that
let's just set the baseline at 12 it's
a.m
it's the the middle of the night is the
first of the next day can we agree on
that
uh yeah that's not the question at hand
but yes
i don't consider that to be the middle
of the night but 3 a.m is kind of late
like the middle of the night
no that's that's not the question do you
consider the middle of night that we're
not finding the middle of the night you
just said we're
considered 3 am the middle of the night
right but so i'm what i meant was
that's a little late it's three i'm okay
forget middle tonight it's the night
like if you're up at 3 a.m you're up
late for me
if you're up at 4 00 a.m you're up early
that's the cutoff
that that's how in my brain without
thinking about it
if if like if i wake up at 4 30
i think to myself dang why do i wake up
so early if i wake up at 3 30 i think
why am i waking up in the middle of
night now that's a good test because
his example is not helpful because i
think
if you haven't gone to sleep then it's
still the night
you can't have a morning until you go to
sleep unless the sun comes up
so as long as the sun's not up and you
haven't gone to sleep it is still
night i don't disagree with you but that
is
i do not believe that is tavin's
question the implication
you go downstairs now the implication is
that you've gone to sleep
if tavin has gone to sleep and he wakes
up but if i
if i go downstairs at 2 a.m the kids
might
still be awake not i've never done three
sometimes i've stayed up till two but if
i've if i've woken up i understand and
but
they haven't gone to sleep i would not
ask them why are you
up so early because they haven't gotten
up but also it's 2 a.m
forget the kid no you i'm saying his
example doesn't work for me
either way okay what about this example
but if but you wake up in the
you wake up at night you look at the
clock it says
3 30. do you think damn
what am i waking up in the middle of the
night for and i'm using i understand
i think it to me i think it's later i
think it's i would say
what do you pick up at 4 30 you wake up
at five
o'clock well five thirty five
okay so it's for somebody who wakes up
at 5 30 and i used to
pre-covet i woke up at 5 50 now i wake
up at 6 30.
so i i think to me it would be
4 30. so 4 20 is
uh 4 20 is still night is
night that's morning for me because i
can think of many different times when
they're like
i gotta go i gotta go on a trip we're
going to the airport
we got to get up at four o'clock and
when i think then i'm like dang that's
gonna be an early morning but if i have
to get up at three o'clock i'm like i'm
not going to sleep yeah for me
it's that the four to five okay well
where i was trying to get to this i was
hoping that you would agree with the
three to four
because i think that there is a
subconscious connection to
what is known as the witching hour which
is traditionally understood to be 3 a.m
to 3 59 a.m i did not know that
so that's what the witching hour is now
people kind of disagree
and first of all is the witching hour
even a thing but
most people agree that that is the hour
that has the highest supernatural
activity right okay people who believe
in supernatural or paranormal things
tend to think that's what they call the
witching hour three o'clock to 3 59.
i didn't do any much reading about this
other than to establish that i didn't
like find out like what's that about
but i just found it interesting that
that hour
is where there's the most extreme
activity and for me
that in my mind is the hour in which the
transition between
night and day is actually happening
which is weird
um based on what just your gut just
based on my gut yeah like i said if it's
four o'clock i feel like
why am i up early if it's 3 30 i'm like
why am i up late
that's i'm again i'm not analyzing it
i'm just saying from the gut that's
what it feels like um but
again i i like to i like to entertain
the possibility of sort of weird
believing weird things it's
it has been proven in my life to be fun
to believe weird things
and i think it's been proven throughout
history that it's fun and attractive to
believe weird things
it's fun to believe conspiracy theories
it's fun to believe in supernatural
things
it makes life more interesting whether
it's true or not
so um i think it's fun to read about it
and other people who believe it but i
don't know if i'll go so far to say
it's fun to actually believe it might be
sad
well it depends on what the implica what
the effect and your personal life is i
guess
but what i'm saying and maybe it's scary
but that time of night that's an
interesting
that is an interesting moment i mean
there's
you can it's it's a sneaky time you know
most
it's it's the least active time you can
get away with the most but there's the
least amount to do
unless you're gonna i guess what which
well i
i think here's my here's the scientific
and again when i say scientific it's in
quotes and has an asterisk next to it
because it's coming from me and i and so
it's not qualified
uh but it could sound qualified to maybe
a person who's not that smart
um i think
that while again it's fun to
believe that there's actual paranormal
things happening
i tend to if i if i'm putting on my
rational hat
i think no it doesn't really happen it's
perception
and it's based on people's patterns
and what state your brain in the world
is
at that time and i just happen to
believe that
and again i have no science to back this
up there's something about your
susceptibility
to seeing things and misinterpreting
things at that hour
based on just our circadian rhythms
right
because you've been asleep you're gonna
say just based on darkness
and well dark tiredness well darkness is
a huge part of it and yeah i mean that's
another way of saying the same thing
if you are if you get up if you've gone
to sleep
right if you stay up to the witching
hour i don't know if they're going to
have the same effect i mean you'll be
getting sleepy and maybe your perception
will be i think it might be worse but
you're prone to hallucinations
perhaps but you're a person who
uh you've never had the opportunity to
see this
but link is a very deep sleeper and he
is a very
like i am he will be
very disoriented upon waking right
i'm a light sleeper and if you wake me
up i might as well be ready to take the
sat like i
i am full i go straight to 100 i'm fully
aware i'm not groggy i'm talking normal
i'm not happy about it i wish i slept
deeper and it would be
probably more enjoyable but link like
there is a
at least two to three minute
stupor that you that you have to kind of
get past before you're fully there right
well especially if it's that
at that time of night yeah and i'm
saying that for me at that time at night
it might as well be the morning i might
be like why am i awake
but i'm also like give me a cognitive
test right now
you know that's an elephant but the
i think that most people are in like a
hindered
state of awareness you're also like
coming out of a dream your mind's in a
weird place
you're gonna see and hear and experience
things and like you said it's
dark and so your mind is gonna you can
play tricks on you you're gonna see
things in the dark
no one else is there to confirm or deny
the things that you see of course you're
gonna have a bunch of weird stories from
that hour
and then over the years it's going to
develop well that's the witching hour
that's where the paranormal activity is
the highest
that's my theory
so but back to back to the question i
mean we've already answered the question
we're only off by an hour by the way
yeah but i think it's a pretty
significant hour
and i'm missing the witchy now and i
would think the interesting thing is you
go to bed
so early that
it's it's and you get up so early it's
weird to me
that your perception of the morning is
all the way into
four o'clock that's just that's strange
to me you go to bed at 9 30. because
this is a it's a minimal impact to me to
get up and at 4
30 an hour earlier but like if you're
if you're buying plane tickets back when
that happened and you're like okay i
gotta
yeah i gotta work backwards from
arriving that means we gotta wake up
at four am versus i mean psychologically
waking up at 5 00 a.m versus four
anything is uh
is a lot worse but three like i'll buy a
plane ticket
if and i would never have three i've
never
bought a plane ticket to get up at three
precisely that you're confirming my
argument
or four okay i've done that in the i've
i've not done plenty of times
we've had in helping a flight where okay
if you got a flight at seven o'clock at
lax
yeah you got to get up at four something
to get there you can't get up at five
i'm like you know what i'm not getting
up before five i just can't do that okay
that's fine but what i'm saying is most
early morning flights are in the seven
something and given how long it takes to
get to lax
and how busy it is you got the family
you got to get the family up
yeah you're going to get up at four
something but i never have gotten the
family up at three something
we will not do that in our household
because that's the witching hour
might see a ghost oh that's why julia483
asks if teleportation was possible
how would it work how would we be able
to do that
on our own or would we need some devices
how expensive would it be
and how would they stop people from
teleporting to places that they should
not
teleport to lots of
questions about teleportation julia
you're thinking a lot about this
so so this is a deconstitution
of your molecules and then a skipping
through space and time
it's impossible and then a
reconstitution of molecules st we're
talking
we're talking trekian situation here
i have i have a more formative uh
question
oh you know about this so you okay that
makes makes the the thought exercise
that julia is inviting us to
partake in even more complicated
uh because you know teleportation is my
superpower of choice because i believe
that it is a it is basically
equivalent to flight uh regardless of
the nature of it because
if i could choose between flight or
teleportation i would choose
teleportation because i could
basically just teleport like an infinite
number of times
and that's my flight or i could just be
the guy who like teleports 100 yards and
then
falls in like a wing squirrel suit and
then teleports again and then
falls some more and then teleport's a
little bit higher you know like i'm
constantly flying that's like i just
i'm just doing it in like the
stratosphere yes yes
but here's the thing and this is the
question aerial teleporting
this is the question for time travel too
and i don't know when this first hit me
and i know that people are probably just
this is not a novel thing but
how do you what is the point of
reference
in terms of your locality
when you are teleporting or time
traveling right
so how and okay let's just take back to
the future right
so we forget we when we think about time
travel
and we think okay well marty mcfly has
got to go back to this exact place in
this exact time
and he's still going to be in the town
that he was in
he's like he's okay literally he's
driving down the road
in the middle of the town and then when
he travels in time he's driving down the
same road in the same town
and that's because in our world our
point of reference is the world
but the world we are on a sphere
if you believe that and uh we are
traveling
not only are we spinning but we're
traveling around the sun
which is also moving through our
in our galaxy in our galaxy what is the
point of reference for time travel or
teleportation
everything's moving so quickly
how did doc brown figure out how to
have the car come back
the points of reference the earth would
be in a completely different place in
1985 than it was in 1955 like
not they would be so it would be so far
from where it was
so did his machine have a way to like
locate where the earth would be
because sure it was relative i mean i
think he wrote it this is not
it's not possible it's relative to the
center of the earth so
i think he wrote it all on a chalkboard
but okay so
in reality like so i don't know this is
easy as writing a script
by the way they said uh
they being some people on the news who
talk about what scientists come up with
they they sent some particle back in
time
like last year or something right like
but like they they
i don't know no they didn't yeah they
did but not like way back in time like
they like made a particle like slip off
of the timeline a little bit i'm
using non-scientific terms for what
actually happened
okay but
it that's a particle moving
a very very very small amount of time
right
i don't really understand the nature of
it and i could be getting this wrong
but like let's say a human moved a year
you're going to be in freaking space man
like
if you move for
in the least you're going to be in a
different country like
and also not on the surface you're going
to be in the earth's crust
you're going to be in the center of the
earth you're going to be on the top of a
mountain you're going to be way high you
but most likely you're going to be
outside of the paper-thin
atmosphere of the earth and no longer
present you're going to be
in just the middle of space if you time
travel
unless they have a point of reference
for being in that exact location
locality
but what is the point of reference if
the universe is constantly expanding
and depending on where you're well no
matter where you are in the universe
you seem like you're in the center of
the universe right
that's one of the that's one of the
understandings of the way that
space and time is expanding is that if
you can go anywhere you want to in the
universe and you always perceive to be
in the middle of it
so there is no point of reference it's
all relative well you talked me out of
wanting to do it
so the first guy who is going to be like
i'm doing it i'm time traveling
hopefully they're like hold on a second
you're not going to end up here again
dude
you're going to die so
don't do it and the same is true with
teleportation unless it's like the kind
of teleportation where you're
oh you can only teleport where you can
see which i think is uh
there was some movie where that was the
case and i don't know why that was the
rule
but you could only teleport where you
could see it sounds safer
and at that point you don't have to
worry about the it's you're moving
instantly and you're moving to a place
you can see so i think that any like
it's not going to be a problem but
anyway that
that's something that complicates the
question for me
too complicated for me julia i got
nothing
josh west asks how important do i have
to be
to be assassinated and not murdered
uh first of all josh i want to um
just send my condolences for your
untimely
demise yeah um and i but i have to point
out that it probably has something to do
with your twitter handle with a handle
like
at stud of the west
i mean he's in try he's trying to be
important i think you're yeah i think
you're you're trying a bit too hard and
it's gonna it is gonna backfire with
uh probably some form of a murder but
watch out for yourself
self-defense he might be the stud of the
west i mean do you know do you think you
are
the stud of the west i just think that's
um i mean i've never heard of the title
and i haven't heard of josh and i think
if
either one existed well i think josh
exists but
there's a lot of the title existed i
think i would have heard of josh
there's a lot of things that exist that
are at least
you know going by what my oldest son
says to me
that are really important and really
popular that we don't that i don't know
about
so stud of the west may be
one of the things that is a big deal in
the west
so well if it is then he's got the only
he he's got the
he's got the twitter handle but i i
think the distinction between
assassination and murdering
is simply political i i like think of
the most popular
non-political person on earth right now
um some pop star
or some athlete right yeah
if if they get if lebron james and again
not speaking anything too
into existence here if lebron james were
killed
you wouldn't say lebron james
assassinated because he's not a
political figure
i think that no they refer to john
lennon's
assassination well i i think it's
that's strange i'm gonna throw out a
couple of things here that's strange to
me is that true
i think just just google it john
lennon's
just well first of all bias google john
lennon's assassination
and just see if it's a thing because to
me the factors are
if you're if you're killed
for an ideological reason
or um to prevent you from accomplishing
something on some
on some scale then i think we might be
in assassination territory well
or if it's if it's done by
well i was going to say if it's done by
a professional but a hit on somebody is
not an assassination
well the wiki entry is the murder of
john lennon
did i say assassination anyway did you
google what i asked i did i said
john lennon assassination and the thing
that was suggested was
john lennon assassin so that the person
who committed it
uh this okay someone who kills a public
figure if an assassination murder
then you are assassinated i don't i
actually think there's a distinction
so what's an assassin is someone who
kills a public figure in a public figure
somebody who kills a public figure in
like a calculated
way not like somebody who kills a public
figure in like a fight
so an assassin
can murder somebody or assassinate
somebody but he's called the perpetrator
wiki and again wiki is the source for
all truth uh
murder resuscitation attempt oh this is
this is
1980 uh
i again i just think you have to be a
political figure so
um obviously like if if the
cia goes to a foreign land and
kills a a leader of a country that's an
assassination
if somebody kills a political leader of
any kind
that's an assassination now if you if
you're like a city councilman
google define assassination i think it
you know
well let's see let's figure it out first
because i think that like that's
probably if you're like the president of
the pta
that's a murder you know if you're like
the head of the school board
even in a big city what is the cut off
if you're a mayor if you're a mayor
that's an assassination unless you're
like a school board
is elected so there's an elected
official
i think if an elected official is killed
in the it's an id there's an ideological
reason or to prevent them from
doing something it's a low-scale
assassination
if who does what i i think if your
assassination is the act of
assassinating someone okay we got it
if i think this i think josh if you want
to be assassinated you're not murdered
you just need to
join a school board things get heated
well
in in okay this this is not you need to
be
what you need to be a political figure
is i think what we're arriving at
this is diff sense i don't know where
that is
um when used as nouns assassination
means the murder of a person
especially for political reasons or for
personal gain
so if you like killed someone to get an
insurance policy no that's not
necessary whereas murder means an act of
deliberate killing of another being
especially
how important do you have to be you have
to be
an elected official it says
assassination is the act of deliberately
killing a prominent
person such as a head of state or head
of government
and assassination may be prompted by
political and military motives
but give me an exa and we need an
example of just like
an athlete being assassinated what was
martin luther king jr assassinated
definitely
100 percent okay that's an assassination
i i know it was
it was it was because he's the leader of
a political movement he was
literally he was a leader of a political
moment a movement
he wasn't an elected official but it was
a political yeah
it could be described as a political
movement yeah
so i'm gonna come up with another
example then if an athlete
or a pop star
is doing something if they're killing
political ideological
bill gates oh he's old that's what he
did
so he's a philanthropist i don't know if
that would be an assassination though
because he's doing uh he's doing all
this
he's doing all this work unless you
believe the conspiracy he's doing all
this work he's doing all this work to
give everybody the mark of the beast to
do a vaccination
that's what he's doing because it's fun
to believe that to help people
if if he's murdered in order
to prevent that then that's an
assassination
but again that's that's socio-political
it's a so it's a social thing yeah
now the stud of the west again um
congratulations on the title let me just
there's a couple things about this
stud implies prominence importance
coolness
probably good-lookingness west implies
implies a region to the left
of the rockies yeah by the left of the
the mississippi mississippi because i
mean yeah east of the rockies is still
technically the west
yep but the west implies a geopolitical
in my mind when you say the west i think
he's talking about the american west
so this is a geopolitical title the stud
of the west is like the best looking
coolest most athletic
dude in this geopolitical
region and as you know what is he doing
if you're good looking
if you're a good athlete you know the
chances of becoming
a prominent politician leading a
political movement go
way up so i would say yeah
if josh if you're killed it will be
clearly an assassination
just by virtue of your twitter handle at
lexor
hello alexandra oh you know what
what are the chances that and this was
not planned
i'm wearing the pen that alexandra made
for me uh of barbara's face chances are
hi you're wearing that a lot
i well i haven't worn on the podcast in
a long time and we're taking one of our
questions
does everyone have a voice inside their
head when they're writing or reading
is that what my voice actually sound is
that what my voice
actually sounds like or is this what i
think my voice sounds like
is it even my voice i don't know if i if
i relate to this because i do not
have a voice that i'm hearing when i'm
reading
i just feel like i'm taking the words
directly to the language center of my
brain and i'm not i don't feel like i'm
translating them into a voice
unless i'm reading a fictional book at
which point
the character may adopt some sort of
voice
and image in my mind but if i'm just
reading words like reading this or an
autobiography you hear the
person who's reading it like when i was
talking about the flea autobiography i
hear him
of course especially because of his
writing style but
yeah right but if you're just reading
like
an email an email don't you do you hear
the person
well see this isn't see what she's
asking is you hear yourself
reading it out loud to yourself because
she's like is that my voice
is this what my voice sounds sounds like
or do i have a special inside my head
voice
let me let me just read some stuff here
silently
it's well now that you're thinking about
it now you're it's impossible
now that i think about it i'm hearing my
voice yeah reading it to me
yeah because you're manifesting that but
if you if you hadn't
been it's just like think don't think of
a pink elephant
what'd you think of a suitcase you
thought of a pink elephant
so you can't do this you can't say what
i thought enough
you're telling me you didn't just
picture a pink elephant i deliberately
didn't but right behind that suitcase
was a pink elephant
it flashed for a second and then i i put
it in a suitcase
right which is the same thing that's
happened in here i i can i can
safely say that just
normal reading of words and also
i mean let's just translate this just to
thoughts in general like when you're
thinking
through something are you like
you know your brain is processing
information
most of the time and you're making a
decision whether or not you're you're
translating that into the english
language right because the english
language is just a proxy for
some things that are happening in the
world right it's just an interpretation
but it isn't
it doesn't actually mean anything
directly it just represents meaning
well definitely when i'm to take one
step back when i'm writing
something i mean definitely an email
when i write an email i write it like
i'm saying it
for the most part but that's i think
that's a it's it's a style choice
not everybody does that some people you
know you can hear them
you can hear more you can hear some
people more than others in their emails
okay because because some people just
they have a writing style
i'm not much of a writer so i think
that's what really come
why i do that i'm more of a verbal
processor so when i
write something down to communicate it i
write down what i would say
if i were there and then if i get in my
head i'll like edit it like crazy
but when you think but when i think
are you like because to me if i'm really
thinking hard i'm not hearing a voice
in my head no there are there are times
because i you know i feel like
you're most people are thinking about
multiple things at once
and then if you like really focus you
might be able i can
generate like an actual sort of like
this is the voice saying the thing like
you should do this almost you know what
i'm saying or whatever
but and this is why it's going to be
really difficult
to ever invent the like mind reading
device
think about all the things that have to
happen like you have to find a way to
interpret
someone's thoughts and then translate
them into
coherent speech that's not even
happening in their brain so how are you
how's that going to happen outside of
their brain
i'm sure there's studies where you know
you can monitor the language center of
the brain when somebody's reading and i
bet you
i bet you there's plenty of people right
now who are listening and thinking
i definitely hear a voice when i read
and when i write i mean
i've said that i hear a voice my voice
when i write
more often yeah yeah yeah yeah but but i
guess that you don't
no i'm saying i can activate that like
now that i'm thinking about it like if
you're writing an email versus a script
when you write the email do you do you
hear yourself
not until i read it back when you read
it back but now when you're writing it
not when i'm
evaluating how does this come across
at that point i might hear a voice but i
do think that's interesting because i
think that regardless of how
you know like uh elon musk's neural link
you know how what is that going to do i
think at best
we're going to be able to sort of
generate interpretations of emotions
like this person is angry
this person is lying this person
is is turned on right now but this
person is thinking this specifically no
way
but you but you could probably have
in addition to the the way that the
brain centers are being highlighted
some sort of ai that gives a pretty
predictable
but not gives a pretty predictable
uh interpretation of what somebody's
thinking
but it won't be like and here's the
sentence related to it
but you'll be but you'll just know based
on the question that you're asking or
the interpretation that they're
the the uh the conversation they're
having what they would be saying and
maybe there's some robot that could like
put it into almost words
digest.bps.org dot uk
says the websites that we pull up
well when you google it is you know it's
the first thing that comes up
a new paper published in psychosis i
love that magazine
suggests that most people do hear an
internal voice when they're reading
for those who heard different inner
voices these tended to vary based on the
voice of the character who was speaking
in a story
or if it was a text message or email
on the voice of the sender uh
you have more than 80 of readers
have inner voice but not everyone shares
the same narrator
while silently reading a book text
message or this article to yourself a
voice may emerge from the back of your
mind to narrate the sentences
eighty percent i just okay i'm not
saying i don't believe that
but i have to believe
that this slows you down like taking the
time
to turn it into a voice doesn't that
make it
like what about people who speed read i
know i don't do that
but there's people who like you can't
you know what i'm saying like you got to
let go of the
the voice i think you gotta let go of
the voice
find a way just to re just to let it go
directly to
i think it's your brain i mean
i'm not convinced i mean you don't think
you do but maybe you do 80
do i said i do when i'm reading
something where
it's a like a character a caricature
voice
you know or it might be but it's not but
maybe i'm misinterpreting this are you
saying that it's it like
the entire thing is being spoken
by somebody that you're hearing in your
head
or is it just like oh i got an email
from link
i'm loosely associating the words that
i'm
reading on this page with the way that
he would say them but it's not a process
that's so fine-tuned that like
every it's he might as well be inside my
head speaking
like that has not happened to me yeah
i'm kind of twisted cause
i every single time i get an email like
if i don't know the person i've got an
email from
or if i'm reading an article i don't i
think i only hear a voice when i know
who it is
exactly and even then what i'm saying is
that it's like a touch and go kind of
thing
i get lost in it and eventually move
beyond the person's voice just to the
content
see i'm reading this freaking article
right now and i i'm hearing myself read
it to myself
i gotta go back to that yeah i can turn
it off it's very comforting
what but what does a person sound like
me
[Music]
boy you've really stumped us here
alexandra
well we've been we've been stumped left
and right here today but
it's been fun it's kind of kind of like
indulging in the conspiracy theory
and i wonder if listening to audio books
which i do
more and more makes this
more likely or less likely you would
think that it has to make it more likely
you know you just get into this place
where i'm just taking in books
as people's voices only
it seems like the easy study is somebody
you hook somebody's brain up
you let them read put a microphone and
then you let them listen to somebody
talk and see if the same part of the
brain lights up
i don't you know it's within the
language center
i don't know let's
do that thanks for making us think about
this stuff
what i'm exhausted you know
sometimes that's all you can do is just
think
you know you're stuck at home
you're not going out to the restaurants
you're not hugging people you haven't
seen your parents
just try to go within yourself and
discover something and just just
listen to that little voice that you
hear
constantly while you're reading or go
outside and play with something you
bought
ah rack time wreck baby wreck baby one
two three
four um when we were at the beach i was
reminded
of this thing this game that exists that
i had forgotten about that i knew about
spike ball i saw i've seen people on the
super popular now yeah
everybody's playing it everybody it's
not so you're saying this isn't much of
a wreck
no no i'm just saying it is the game of
choice on the beaches now it's
yeah it's the new it's a new corn hole
for the beach that's the name of it i
didn't know the name of it spike
spike ball so it's like a hula hoop with
a net stretch
reasonably taut over it and then it's
got four
um legs and then you got this little
ball
and you just bat it down like serve it
bounce it off and then you can i think
you play volleyball rules yeah
volleyball then you can hit it twice to
yourself
and then hit it back over if you're just
playing against somebody at least that's
how we're doing it at our house
oh so have you done the four-way game i
i have not
mobilized four people in my family at
all participation i watched
uh i watched a four-way game at the
beach that seems the most fun
and uh i surmised it was you could not
touch it twice yourself
that was like volleyball you had to hit
it to your partner i mean it's
lincoln and lando play you know even
with the age discrepancy they have a
good time playing so he's better than
tetherball
yeah yeah it's better than tetherball if
you're thinking about getting a
tetherball don't
okay we need to it needs to die
tetherball needs to go we have one
yeah and have you used it well there was
a pole that we would walk to and hook it
up
and yeah yeah and when was the last time
you did that i can't even remember
tetherball only exists
i was a joke in entertainment when it
jammed
the crap out of my finger when i was
playing tell the ball is just an
accident waiting to happen uh
spike ball you can you can get one on
amazon for less than 30 bucks
a whole set that's a pretty good deal
you know you
even you know if you've if you play five
times you pay for the thing
you know wait why because you charge six
dollars every time
yeah oh you said fifteen dollars or
thirty dollars just a thirty dollar
thirty dollars okay yeah
six i was right first time yeah so hey
try it out even with just two people
it's still fun and then it's
and it's lightweight you can take it to
the beach it can't
eat i don't think maybe it fits in a
carrier i don't know
it does fit in a carrier because i was i
think you can assemble it i was on the
beach that you had to like walk down the
steps to get to
i don't know i think my 30 dollar one
does that and the guy had it in like a
backpack and he like broke it out and i
was like whoa okay here we go
try out spike ball if you if you get
someone who likes to
knock balls with you it seems to be much
more enjoyable when you're intoxicated
just based on
my experience watching the game um
it's also harder when you're holding a
beer in one hand i think my kids would
concur
okay spike ball spike it up yeah look at
that social distance anything to get
these kids doing something outside
for a few minutes hell you can do that
inside oh you could do it inside yeah
yeah it gets it kind of out of control i
wouldn't do that
don't do it outside don't do it inside i
mean do it outside
just just let me finish this that's it
do it outside okay as long as you're not
alone
let us know what you thought about the
discussion this week hashtag gear
biscuits you probably know something we
don't cause
yeah we were just really give us the
real science give us the real science on
twitter the source of all truth
i want to know if if you hear a voice
let's talk about that specifically
that's an interesting one
hashtag air biscuits talk at you next
week to watch more ear biscuits click on
the playlist on the right to watch the
previous episode of your biscuits click
on the playlist to the left and don't
forget to click on the circular icon to
subscribe
if you prefer to listen to this podcast
it's available on all your favorite
podcast platforms
thanks for being your mythical best
[Music]
you